Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
Okay. So picking back up with the last video.
And captain Britain, Brian, Bradick being resurrected, uh,
by Merlin and his daughter Roma. Of course,
once he gets back into the main Marvel universe, which is where he is right now,
he ends up kind of traveling back to the Braddock mansion and going back home
and visiting for time. But almost as soon as he gets there,
he's immediately set upon by a handful of enemy forces.
And these guys basically identify themselves as being part of a group called the
special collective now,
but the special collective really kind of comes here and manages to topple.
Brian Brodick quite readily. I mean, not that it's not an absolute, you know,
crushing experience. He's not, you know, completely and totally obliterated. Uh,
but he is defeated, you know, pretty handedly.
And the reason why here is because once the special collective gets their hands
on him and they ended up, uh,
end up taking him to essentially where it is that he's supposed to be.
We end up finding out that he's being brought before Saturday.
And the reason for this is that in the aftermath of everything that happened in
earth, two 38,
that the belief of the Omni Bristol development court is at Saturday and had
failed, but she had done something wrong and screwed something up.
Now there's also a couple of things going on here, right?
And we won't necessarily cover it in,
or it's not really covered in this particular comic,
but we can go ahead and cover it. Now,
this is the early indication of the captain Britain core.
Basically the idea that Brian Bradick is not the only captain Britain that
exists out there,
that every single universe has its own version of Brian Brodick.
And that each one of these versions are designed for the purpose of trying to
protect that particular universe. Now, the other thing to understand is a cabin.
Britain's not really designed to be this kind of all encompassing NY
indestructable character capable of protecting his universe. Instead,
he's just kind of a person who can kind of bring the core together if there's a
threat significant enough or something along those lines. Now,
for the most part,
the captain Britain core on the whole is not really invoked in this story
because it's still relatively new. And again,
the main focus was focusing on captain Britain, himself, as opposed to,
you know, anything else that could have been involved in this particular story,
but for Saturday,
and because of the fact that she's being held here under the belief that she has
failed, when Brian encounters her,
she initially believes that he like enjoys this, right?
Seeing her basically being subdued, being held as a prisoner, uh,
because of the fact that she'd failed in such a way,
especially because she abandoned him and everybody else on earth, two 38,
and kind of just did it to seemingly saver on hype. But at the end of the day,
he says, no,
that's not really my intention here now for what we're seeing in extra swords
right now, which is Saturday and being for the most part in love,
or at least pursuing Brian, Bradick it all really kind of starts here.
Once the trial begins to take place,
we ended up finding out that the person who's presiding over this,
the judge of this whole trial is a guy by the name of man dragon.
And the reason why this is a big deal is because man, dragon,
while being the judge is also the person who's going to take over the role for
Saturday and he covets power. And so in essence,
basically the guy who's going to take her place is the guy presiding over her
trial. You see the conflict of interest there, right?
One of the first things they do here,
when this all kicks off is the universal development court led by man dragon
kind of looks around and says, given everything that's happened in earth,
two 38, my scientific advisors have been, this Jasper's work is still going on.
If we let this go unchecked, if we do not find a way to control this,
it's going to spread from that universe into the entirety of the multi-verse and
that this guy will basically twist and distort the whole multi-verse right.
Meaning it'll have to be wiped, clean and started again.
The only way for us to contain this is to destroy his universe seemingly with
the press of a button, right? The turn of a key,
they wipe out the entirety of the earth, two 38 universe. Now the good,
the funny thing about the Omni Vestal development cord is that this is a concept
that you're not really going to see very often anymore in Marvel comics.
And that's because by the time you got into the late 1980s going into the early
1990s, and the idea of just so many cosmic based stories,
especially when you have infinity gauntlet and the, the,
the idea of the living tribunal playing such a prominent role in that story and
achieving a huge amount of popularity.
But let me try Bina would start to become the go-to source for dealing with
multi-vessel problems.
And that's why the Omni erosive element court kind of took a back seat,
but while that's happening, the fury is still in earth, two 38.
And so even when that entire universe is destroyed, the fury survives.
And the reason why is because the furious power set is such that it adapts to
the powers of anybody at faces against right,
its number one protocol is survival.
It'll do whatever it needs to do in order to survive.
And so when this whole universe has destroyed,
the fury basically finds a way to survive the destruction of this universe and
then just exists in this giant empty void and is constantly haunted by the one
desire to track down captain Britain and to kill him. It never gives up.
That's kind of what we're constantly told here.
And so what ends up happening is we kind of jumped back for a second to the
early days of earth, two 30, eight of that universe when everything popped off,
right? When, when Jim Jaspers first started seizing power.
And when he created the fury and we pick up with captain UK,
a woman by the name of Linda, but we pick up with her and her husband, Rick,
in that universe,
when it was basically them just kind of taking refuge from the fury, right?
At this point, the Fury's killed pretty much everybody, right?
Like gets killed everybody across the world.
And they're really like the only ones left.
And so when the fury breaks in here immediately, awesome.
Andy starts going on a goat going after it. And Andy Android,
to give you guys perspective in the main Marvel universe,
Andy Android was powerful enough to lift Thor's hammer, right?
That's why he's called awesome. Andy. He's a really,
really powerful construct to be destroyed by it like this by the fury really
says something right from there. The fury goes in a miracle, man,
tears them up as well. Like kills him.
All these guys just start falling and dying everywhere.
And it ultimately comes down to captain UK, Linda,
and it comes down to her husband, Rick, and there's nothing they can do.
And so what,
what Rick ends up doing is actually putting her into a universal teleporter.
That'll teleporter to an alternate reality. He sticks her in there.
She basically tells him to look out, he's killed right?
As the device is activated, she teleports away and she watches her husband die.
And so that's really kind of where her PTSD and her anxiety came from.
She was there watching as the fury was killing every single superhero on earth
and there was nothing she could do to stop it.
And so once you get back to the main trial itself,
you have a Brian Britta cruise there basically as a, as a,
a defense for Saturday night. And as soon as, as this world is destroyed,
he kind of starts to get off and starts to freak out. Right?
And that alone is kind of a strike against him by the court.
Why they're just kind of looking for reasons to discredit this guy.
And so one Saturday is able to issue her defense.
She basically says that like the push went exactly the way that it was supposed
to. And it happened exactly the way that it was supposed to. Right.
Everything was fine. We don't know,
like the only thing that we can surmise here is that some kind of reality storm
took place, right?
Somebody somewhere out there did something that basically twisted that reality
up, right? It was not us. We didn't screw anything up.
We did the push the same way we've done it countless times before Brian Bradick
was an unexpected involvement in this, but by no means, were his actions,
the ones responsible for this, right?
There was this fury thing that was out there and it was trying to kill everybody
we got out while we could. And we figured we'd fix the problem later.
And so once that, once that defense is offered,
the expectation is that Brian is going to be the one to testify,
but immediately he shot down by man dragon.
And the idea of man dragon is you basically says this case you're presenting is
nonsense. I don't believe it. I don't really believe anything.
You're telling me right now. Not only that you brought this guy,
captain Brittany here to testify, but I believe the two of you were lovers.
And I believe that he's been instructed to lie in court to secure your
acquittal. So I'm not even going to let him testify in the first place, right?
It's obviously a kangaroo court, right? It's a farce. And so when Brian brought,
it gets, that's it, right.
They basically end up restraining him and they call it a day.
And so Saturday Nene is essentially sentenced to execution. Right? See,
sit sentenced to be,
to be executed really that everything that happened in earth, two 38,
and it's supposed to be the end of her.
What ends up happening instead is that Brian Brodick basically breaks free of
his confines.
He grabs Saturday and along with a handful of others and they basically take off
right. The special collective Saturday and Brian Bradick,
they bail now for the most part, man,
Dragon's not really off about this because in his mind, it's kind of like, okay,
that's basically fine because all it does is just really go more towards her
guilt.
So I can use that against her when she's captured and the trial recommences,
but for the character of Linda, right, captain UK in the main, uh,
the main Marvel universe,
the reason why this is also important here is because she ends up grabbing the
morning newspaper and her worst dreams begin to come from, come to fruition.
When you find out that magnesium Jasper is in the main Marvel universe is doing
exactly what Jim Jaspers and the alternate universe did in our two 38 dead.
He starts calling for superhero legislation to outlaw superheroes, right?
So everything that's happened before is happening again, like to pro,
to quote Battlestar Galactica, right?
And so with the special collective and with Ryan Braddock,
and those guys basically toppling the forces who were there,
they ended up making their escape and they're officially,
officially ended up traveling back to the Bradick mansion. Now,
while all that happens, while that's going on, once they get there,
you end up having captain UK, Linda who shows up here. Now,
normally the captain Britain characters, right?
These different versions of captain Britain from across the multiple are
supposed to be exceedingly brave characters.
This girl is terrified because she looks at what's going on. And she's like,
history is repeating itself, switch to a TV,
a TV kind of broadcast by Jim Jasper's himself,
basically the prime minister of London now. And he basically, you know,
using his powers to achieve that, that goal. He basically says,
I'm calling on legislation to be passed,
to ban the superheroes who are out there, right.
To ban also be heroes in London, right. To get rid of all that stuff.
If they can be trusted, why are they wearing masks? Right.
There are people out there with a huge amount of power that have the ability to
literally wipe out entire right. We have to get rid of these guys.
It's basically fear-mongering. And so following that,
you ended up having Brian who speaks directly with Linda, you know,
and she's like, it's the exact same speech he made in my universe,
the exact same lines, right? The exact same statements, all of it, right?
It's all basically the same thing.
Everything that happened before is going to happen again in this universe.
And there's nothing we can do to stop it. Now, from there,
you switch over to the very little involvement that you get with the rest of the
Marvel universe. When you have Jim Jasper's meeting with Henry Peter Guy,
Rick and Sebastian shot.
And the reason why this matters is because this takes place during Chris
Claremont's run on the eczema. And so because of that,
because Jim Jasper's is a mutant,
it made sense to kind of cross those two things over.
Remember in America at the time that all this is happening with Jim Jaspers and
America, you have operation wide awake, right?
So you have project wide awake being launched by the federal government for the
purpose of containing and controlling the mutant threat. In essence,
Jim Jasper's seems to share the same ideologies as Henry Peter Goddard and
Sebastian shot.
What they don't know is that his intention is not to truly safeguard Britain.
His intention is to conquer the world.
These guys are completely and totally oblivious to the fact that they are
standing in the presence of what is an effect,
the most powerful mutant in the universe.
But we start to see the small little ways in which Jim Jaspers is able to use
its powers and a far more nuanced measure and comparison to his counterpart from
earth two 38 when he has a glass of white wine,
which he despises and he changes it into red wine, right? It's small,
it's subtle,
but it's a huge differentiation because it means that his ability to control his
powers are far more nuanced than the version from earth, two 38.
He was relatively new.
And that's when you have Roma and Merlin kind of watching all this unfold and
they say, okay, the game now begins, right? The test of,
of Jim Jasper's is can he pull this off?
And so what he ends up doing is actually calling a woman by the name of Vixen.
Now, Vixen is a character who was a foe of captain Britain for quite some time.
But one of the things that kind of goes on here in the captain Britain stories
is you had the formation of a group called strike the,
the special tactical reserve for international key emergencies and strike was
basically a organization that operated inside Britain that served the purpose of
quelling threats that went beyond any particular intelligence agency's ability
to handle. Am I five of my six,
whatever those intelligence agencies are in Britain. I'm not really.
With those. They're not really equipped to handle people with superpowers,
but strike is. But in order to ensure that strike function,
according to what it was a Jim Jasper's wanted,
he actually orchestrated a situation where Vixen was able to infiltrate strikes.
She's basically a Crow, a crime ward. And so she basically runs the show.
And so,
because she's the one running strike strike is now effectively the personal army
of Jim Jaspers.
And he tells her that like within a week strike will receive direct orders from
the British governor, our government to eradicate all the superheroes.
And that's exactly what happens, right?
That seemingly within like within a few days or so that every single superhero
that we can find is captured. But every single superhero in that, uh, in,
in London itself is captured and they're thrown into internment camps.
And this is all happening the way that it happened in the earth,
two 38 universe, right? Ben interment camp for creative,
for individual superpowers. And out over time, they were destroyed, right?
They were completely and totally eradicated as to what you ended up getting here
is that we're Linda kind of panics and can't really handle it.
She basically storms off and leaves.
She's confronted by the fury who basically managed to find a way to teleport
from his universe,
from what was the two 38 universe into the main mobile universe, right?
The name of the game of that guy's powers is adaptation.
If he has a target he's going after and he's aware that target still exists,
he can try anywhere in the universe.
That's the power of the gym Jasper's bestowed upon it and is in the alternate
reality like that,
that alternate universe version of Jim Jasper's gave the fury the power to track
down any target, no matter where they may be.
And it was probably one of these things where Jim Jaspers did it.
Open-ended never really believing that he would be destroyed and that the Fury's
directive would allow it to actually transition from one universe to the next.
And that's one of the things that makes the theory so incredibly powerful.
This is a guy that can jump from one universe to another tracking a target,
and is designed to adapt to anybody's power.
Now where the theory goes against an attacks,
Linda captain UK from earth two 38, Brian,
Bradick happens to show up just in the Nick of time.
And ultimately this leads to Brian Bradick facing off against the fury again.
And that's when he's like the furious here, right? Like this thing is finally,
this thing is back here.
It killed me before it eradicated all the superheroes on it's world.
There's no real possible way for us to defeat this thing, right?
This thing is wildly powerful.
And so what you end up getting is the special collective responding at the
direction of Sater nein going after the fury to save Brian Bradick and to save
Linda special collective has never experienced the fury before.
They've never come across this guy before.
And so their leader just kind of runs headlong into it. Like, come on guys,
we got this. And their, their leader gets totally crushed, right? From there,
the special collective attacks and they get totally crushed, right?
So like they went into this under the direction of their leader,
believing that their leader knew what was best for them and totally failed.
Right. They all almost died.
And so in response to that special collective is like, we're not doing this.
This is too much right. Like what this is now, this is,
this is way beyond what you're paying us to do, right?
Because they are basically bounty hunters by they're mercenaries,
not really bounty hunters, but they're mercenaries. And they're like,
we're not doing this, right. This is not happening.
And so it basically leads to the special collective bailing out.
But the theory going through and attacking all these guys brings back all this
PTSD, Linda of all the experiences she had, right.
Watching all these superheroes, well, I, and fail to defeat this force.
That's not unstoppable. Now.
The fury is kind of weakened by the special collective,
but only enough for it to basically be halted, right.
Only enough for it to kind of be stocked for a minute.
And by the special collective time to basically get out right.
To basically make their escape there. And so once they end up leaving,
it's really just kind of left to Brian Saturn, Dean Betsy Brodick.
And that's really it.
I just really only left to them to just kind of do the best they can to stave
off this measure of power. And so following the,
the application of all these internment camps, right? All these,
these concentration camps where they're rounding up various powered beings,
they're throwing them in these camps and they're leaving them there with the
expectation or the intention of executing them at a future point in time,
the fury is still on the hunt for captain Britain, but at the same time,
Vixen as the head of strike begins to come to this realization that Jim Jasper's
is dangerous and that he needs to be stopped, right?
There's something else going on here besides the fact that he's just the prime
minister and that he's ordering the execution of all these superheroes.
That's something bad is going on besides that.
Now you'd think that would be bad enough,
but there's something else in the various happening.
And so she travels to 10 Downing street, I think is what it's called,
which is the location of where the prime minister resides.
Basically kind of like Britain's version of the white house.
If there was such a thing British members of the Rob poor,
you guys can correct me on that. But as soon as she gets in there,
everything is topsy turvy.
And that's when she realizes she screwed up,
she screwed up in the worst way.
That, uh,
he starts using his powers and stretching out and stirring up her henchmen,
turning them into like these just kind of monstrous and grotesque things.
And then he in turn,
uses his powers and transforms her into an actual Vixen right into a female Fox.
And so again, the power of Jim Jasper is being able to rematerialize things,
transform a person into something else.
That's the kind of power that we're talking about here. And so from there,
you basically pick up with, uh,
with Brian coming to this realization that with Jim Jasper's existing in his
universe, that he has to confront him, right.
That he has to confront Jim Jasper's head on. And so once he ends up,
what he ends up doing is traveling again to Downey street itself.
And as soon as, as he walks in there, everything's on fire.
Everything's kind of twisting, turning, right?
It's all completely and totally screwed up.
The laws of physics have completely and totally gone awry here.
And so once he opens the door, he's kind of met by this statement, right?
The statement where he's, he's basically told, you know, can I help you, sir?
You appear to be lost, lost in the fun house.
And it's just this enormous receipt of Jim Jasper's this just huge and scale
right there. Seemingly be like,
he literally walked into his office and it turned into a universe.
That's the power of Jim Jasper's to skew and to break the laws of physics. Now,
from there, you ended up picking up with, uh,
with Saturnian confronting Linda and we're,
Linda's kind of terrified by everything going on. She was like,
you have to go help him, right? Like he can't do this on his own.
You have to go help him. Like you're our only real chance here.
And she's kind of gripped by fear, paralyzed by fear, anxiety,
the PTSD she's experienced the terrible situations.
So Saturday starts goading her while she's like, you're a cower.
Then you let your world die. You let your lover die.
You let everybody that you care about die because you're a coward.
You're no measure of a captain Britain at all, right?
Like we failed Merlin and Roma. They failed in bringing you on. Right.
You are not any kind of real measure of a superhero.
I know that because you're sitting here sniffling like a little child afraid of
the big, bad guy. And that's when Linda starts to freak out,
finally regains her courage and the face of her anger and then says, okay, fine.
So like she ended up Donnie or captain UK uniform intending to go directly
after, uh, after captain Britain and to help save him from,
from Jim Jasper's right. To help them defeat Jim Jaspers.
And the funny thing about this is that you end up having this thing where you
have captain Britain, this, this is, this is, this is kind of nuts here, right?
This is, this is immature stuff. This is crazy. He confronts the Jim Jaspers.
And he says like, if you're even remotely saying you can't do this ride,
Jim Joshua is like, I'm not, I'm not saying, and I can do this. And he's like,
fine. Then I'll fight you with every breath in my body.
And then he suddenly wakes up. He's there with Jack doll.
He's there with Saturday. And he's like, jacked off. I thought you were dead.
He was like, no, man, like we're facing off against some enemies here,
but you've just been babbling, like a madman. Right.
You just been battling like a madman going on about nothing is everything. Okay.
And so you're kind of given this indication that what we've been experiencing
here in this universe is actually a dream right.
In the main Marvel universe is actually a dream.
And instead they're just kind of facing off against this crazy threat.
But as he's talking to Jack Dawn,
as he's talking to Saturday and he kind of reaches over,
he pulls down what looks like this giant sheet, this fabric.
And like literally the whole scene comes tearing down. Well,
like a piece of paper. And then suddenly he's at a hospital and it's like,
nurse he's awake. Right? Like you can't possibly have. Right. I mean like,
this is, this is crazy that he's basically talking to his mother. Right.
And it's, it's kinda like, you know, like, this is, this is sort of nuts, right?
This is kind of crazy. Like, you know, he has amnesia, you know, and that,
that he's finally awake, you know? And that he was in a car accident up in,
in dark more. So he never became captain Britain. This reality starts shifting.
And that's when you have him pop back up to Jim Jasper. And he's like you said,
you were telling me something about fighting me with every breath in your body.
Like you're hopelessly outclassed. That's the power of Jasper's right?
Like imagine a story, like imagine the events of house of M that's,
what Jasper's is doing here to captain Britain.
That's a level of power we're talking about here. Guys,
a guy who could basically rewrite all of reality around a singular person and
then trick them into believing that things are the way they are screwing with
his head. Of course, you ended up having Ryan who,
once he realizes what's going on, he's like, you don't belong here. Right.
This power you have, you know,
you're using it for evil means like I'm going to kill you.
I'm going to destroy you. That's when Jasper starts messing with him again,
right. Snapping his fingers. He's in hell snap, his fingers. Again, he's in,
he's in a classroom snap his fingers again, after that,
like he's inside of a weed eater, right?
Like he's just inside of like a Bush Hawk snapping his fingers again and again
and again and again,
and everything around Brian Braddock is just twisting and changing and skewing,
but it's nuts.
And all this means is that Brian Brodick is painfully out of his league.
He has no answer for Jim Jaspers.
And the funny thing about this is that the way in which Jim Jaspers is defeated,
doesn't even come from, from, uh, from Brian Bradick himself instead,
seemingly out of nowhere with him finally tracking down Brian Bradick,
the fury goes on the attack and he immediately starts going after Brian
Braddock, right. Starts pummeling him.
He ends up breaking his arm by just beating the absolute hell out of the sky.
And so what is happening here is a Jim Jasper basically creates the crazy gang
out of nowhere. Right. Just kind of creates them out of dirt. And it's like,
I created everything in existence and I need you guys to defeat Brian it,
but then like, as soon as the fury shows up, he's like, I never created that.
That's weird. And so we started looking at the fury starts kind of examining it.
Right. It's just kind of like, you're a little strange, like, I mean,
I feel like I've met you before, but this is a little weird,
but the theory is looking at Jim Jaspers and the fury is like, okay,
I was programmed to not kill Jim Jaspers.
But that program came from an alternate reality.
That was the alternate reality version of Jim Jasper's. This is not that guy.
So my programming should allow me to kill him.
And so basically the fury goes after Jim Jaspers and what you get here is the
Fury's ability to adapt versus Jim Jasper's ability to control reality.
An unstoppable force meets an immovable object is what this is.
And so every time Jim Jaspers launches an attack, the fury adapts,
right it's attack, adapt attack, adapt attack,
adapt it's over and over and over again by just constantly.
And the more that Jim Jaspers attacks, the more the fury adapts.
So the power starts to become more and more extreme to the point where they
rewrite reality and they're fighting on the moon.
Then they changed reality and they're fighting on the sun that change reality
they're fighting in help you reality is shifting in such a way that with Merlin
watching all this unfold and actually overwhelms his mind and kills him. Now,
the funny thing about this is that Merlin actually fakes his death.
He's not actually debt. Oh, that was a way for,
for them to kind of make them appear dead and then have him create Excalibur and
Marvel comics. That's really kind of where that comes from,
but they keep rewriting reality and changing things, right.
And everything keeps getting screwed up around them,
keeps getting skewed to the point that they're actually turning into creatures
that don't even really exist. But it's basically this,
these two guys facing off against each other and the fury comes to this
realization. This fight would be limitless,
but this fight would go on forever and ever.
And they would actually end up destroying all of reality and the process, right?
Because the powers would just get so extreme,
more and more altering of reality would take place as the fury kind of starts
calculating, like while this fight is going on,
the fury starts calculating and says,
there's only actually one way to end this fight.
So we switches and he teleports Jim Jaspers to earth two 38,
where there is no universe because the fury figured out that Jim Jasper's powers
require him to have a universe to alter.
And that right there is the difference between adult Franklin Richards and Jim
Jasper's that Jim Jaspers has to have,
has to have a universe to create anything in, right.
That he's not really creating something out of nothing.
He's just altering the existing fabric of the universe.
He has to have a reality in order to alter Franklin Richards.
We saw in Jonathan, Hickman's a fantastic fork.
He can create something out of nothing,
or he can just create a universe out of nothing.
So like we've seen him do that before.
So that's the huge difference between these two guys,
but with Jim Jasper as being in a place where there is no universe,
then basically he's powerless. He's just an average guy.
The fury puts his hands to his head fries, his brain.
And that's the end of Jim Jasper's following that the fury ends up traveling
back to the main Marvel universe with the intention of going after captain
Britain. The problem with this is that all that effect of reality,
warping and adapting to the various forms that Jim Jasper's was taking on,
took a huge toll on the fury and pushed him to the extreme so much so that he is
exceedingly weakened. And so because of that,
it offers Brian Brodick alongside Linda, the one chance they need to destroy it.
And that's exactly what they do,
but they use their powers and completely annihilate the fury really,
really more Linda. They basically saved by biotic than anything else,
but they completely and totally obliterate the fury. And that ends that right?
The Fury's destroyed. Jim Jasper's is destroyed,
but the caveat to this is it Saturday and realizing the power that you could
potentially possess here actually ends up extracting a DNA sample of Jim
Jasper's. Now this is important.
The reason why I really want to include this in here.
And the reason why it's important is because I would surmise the next time that
we see Jim, Jasper's basically in Marvel.
The next time we see him is an X-Men die by the sword, I believe.
And it is in the aftermath of house of M and that you end up seeing him
re-emerge buddies and he's merged with a fury, right? That's not real.
That doesn't really seem to be anything that, uh,
that Hickman is following in his, uh, excess swords event.
And so what this looks like,
is it Saturday made good that she actually ended up cloning Jim Jaspers and he's
the one that runs a crooked market, right? He's a recreation of Saturday.
Now she may have altered his mind altered his memories. We don't really know,
but regardless of the situation, what this does is it leads to a funeral,
kind of a funeral for Merlin, even though he's not actually dead. Right.
And basically the day has been saved right.
Saturday and just kind of has an ASAP for sleep, which he uses our man dragon,
right? She ends up going to visit man dragon. And she's like,
you're going to give me a full pardon.
Otherwise I'm going to take this clone body of Jim Jasper's that we're treating
right now.
And I'm going to unleash it on your world and let him just lose his mind and go
crazy. So of course she gets a full pardon.
She's returned back to being in the position of magistrates.
That's kind of how she maintained,
maintain her possession ever since the days basically saved. Right. You know,
that's kind of how the story ends, but you know,
I wanted to throw this out there and I wanted to, to bring this to you guys,
because I thought it was important to understand the power Jasper's has and why
him being in X's sword is potentially a massive credible threat, right?
Because this guy has a ridiculous level of power. So with that being said, guys,
we're going to bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain,
make sure you guys hit the sub button to become part of the Rob port.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a like,
and I will catch you all later.
[Inaudible].